[Aplausos]
pues la historia comienza así yo quería
pedir la santa unos regalos desde que
era muy chiquita pero me tardé bastante
tiempo en atreverme porque lo que le
quería pedir a él era un balón de fútbol
unos tacos y unos guantes de portero así
que hasta que tuve ocho años me atreví
porque yo crecí con todo mi entorno y la
gente que me rodeaba diciéndome que el
fútbol era para hombres entonces ya cómo
le voy a pedir a santa que me traiga
esto no es para mí el fútbol qué mala
onda estaría meterlo en este rollo
porque tú santa te trae normalmente lo
que no pides pero como lo voy a meter yo
en esta encrucijada de decirle que me
traiga un balón unos guantes y unos
tacos si el fútbol no es para mujeres
pero la verdad es que me ganó la pasión
y se mi cartita la puse en el árbol
santa se la llevó
normalmente cuando haces eso pues ya
estás muy contento de que santa te va a
traer tus regalos y te urge que sea esa
noche para recibirlos y yo no en ese
momento justo era todo lo contrario
estaba nerviosísima esperando a que
llegara el día para ver qué pasaba no lo
iba a traer santa o no me lo iba a traer
esa noche por supuesto no dormí nada
me desperté más temprano que toda mi
familia y mi casa es de dos pisos salí
de mi cuarto
y me parece justo para sumarme al balcón
que daba al arbolito lacko que con 33
123 y me asomé al largo
y que creen
a ver los que quieren que se hagan
regalos
o sea antes malísima honda segundo
ustedes ok
los demás pues que creen que sí que sí
había regalos ahí está mi balón mis
tacos y los guantes pero qué creen
eran todos rosas
guantes rosas balón rosas y tacos rosas
supongo que una manera muy sutil de sant
a decirme que está padrísimo pidió jugar
a fútbol pero que no se me olvidará que
yo era niño
juego fútbol desde que tengo 3 años de
edad mi familia
árabe y mexicana son culturas que son
muy dedicadas al hombre le podemos
llamar culturas machistas incluso yo soy
hija mayor y soy nieta mayor pues
imagínense lo que fue mis abuelitas
están aquí no me van a dejar mentir
que llegará yo con un balón y me querían
convencer de lo contrario como oye mira
el ballet el tutú rosa tan femenino y
estilizado y yo mi pelota no pero la
gimnasia tan bonita y tan para mujer y
yo me balón y todas las tardes me sale a
mi jardín a practicar marco que pone a
ser dominadas como la virtud 10 no voy
por dispo blowing y le grita mi mamá
para que se asoma por la ventana para
que viera lo que yo estaba haciendo si
me ponía dominar cañón y mamá decía
bueno esta niña porque está aprendiendo
de dónde está aprendiendo a hacer todo
esto y bueno es que toda mi vida crecí
jugando con puros niños y es la historia
de todas las que jugamos fu desde hace
mucho tiempo eran siempre puros niños y
yo el esquema siempre y me acuerdo
perfecto llegué yo una vez a las metas
en el parque villa a ver don que era
como súper suites o que tus como bien
rudo y mis amigos de no posiblemente cai
link
eran como 50 niños club de tobi así
yo apanicada atrás de un árbol viendo la
cancha y aparte en ese momento cuando
eres chiquita como quisiera mujer eres
como alienígena objeto volador no
identificado
eres como la otredad total entonces una
coca
mangué mi playera
merriman en los fans
y me puse mi gorra para atrás
y estoy caminando a la cancha así
obviamente era mi manera para que fuera
ellos como aceptada mi gorra era rosa
entonces si querías que rueda me veía
pues tampoco pero bueno así yo me sentía
más en mí pues ya empecé a jugar y
resulta que no solamente jugaba que
jugaba muy bien y en eso era la
sensación pasaba de haber sido eso que
nadie reconocía la extrañeza que estaba
rompiendo nuestro club de tobi a la niña
que jugaba fútbol que jugamos muy bien
fútbol y de repente ya tenías a la porra
te saluda por acá laporta te saluda por
allá la venta va en balones de darle
beso y mandámelo entonces era como el
otro extremo pero toda la vida siempre
era llegar a demostrar llegaba ya una
cancha de fútbol con puros niños me
veían raro veías que es insana secrète
al quedan con cara debuta por suerte
está en tu equipo y en eso empezarás a
jugar y la historia cambia jugué con
niños hasta mis 18 años hasta que entré
estudiar aquí a la ibero que por primera
vez entré a jugar fútbol 11
porque yo está acostumbrada a jugar
siempre en el parque y en la calle y no
sólo eso a un equipo de mujeres de puras
mujeres
ya dije regresen me con mis amigos por
favor
obviamente el ambiente es muy diferente
pero ahora si tú ya estaba yo jugando
fútbol en serio entrenando todos los
días teniendo partidos los fines de
semana
y se puso buena la cosa de hecho también
preguntan cómo hacen que estudia si yo
súper fuerte se ha hecho y futbolista
no soy comunicóloga soy futbolista y
hasta ahí creí que había llegado por
supuesto extendí mi carrera lo más que
pude para seguir jugando fútbol aquí
porque era lo que tenía emociones
entonces que era lo más cercano a ser
futbolista profesional universiadas
competencia contra las universidades
pero también a nivel de julio- joven
colombiano en eeuu y pensé que ayuda ahí
se había acabado mi historia del fútbol
hasta que hace un par de años me
invitaron a participar en un blog en el
que éramos varias empresarias que
teníamos la cualidad de aparte ser
deportistas y la idea justo era platicar
cómo es que el deporte te da aptitudes
de liderazgo de disciplina de compromiso
para emprender escribía yo regularmente
cada 15 días y un día se me ocurrió
hablar de la igualdad de género en el
fútbol
pues resulta que ese artículo se hace
vital en redes sociales se viralizó no
tengo idea como no me pregunten la
estrategia no había estrategia se
viralizó yo creo que yo tenía no sé
doscientos followers en twitter nomás y
me empezó a escribir la gente fuera esta
increíble tu campaña oye tengo una hija
que juega pero gigante que la escuela
sólo hay clases para niños oye mi
sobrina juega pero no hay escuela para
ella donde la pudo meter tendrás algún
lugar a donde la pues recomendar y yo
empecé a leer todo esto y dije no pues
en 26 años después de que empecé a jugar
fútbol y todo sigue igual para las
mujeres en el deporte no hay apoyo no
hay oportunidades y las niñas que
quieren ser futbolistas no pueden ser
futbolistas
recibo una llamada del periódico récords
fuera esta increíble tu campaña de
fútbol te queremos entrevistar
así que mi artículo de opinión de fútbol
y ya que estaba lloviendo todo eso que
está pasando en las redes sociales dije
alguien tiene que levantar la voz yo ya
no puedo quedarme callada y solamente
hacer un artículo de opinión las niñas
tienen que cumplir sus sueños y fue como
decidí empezar a hablar ya echarme el
saco al hombro para pedir que se creara
una liga profesional de fútbol me llegó
un mensaje por twitter luís garcía
hay que achicar que la cuenta estuviera
verificadas y de palomita azul por favor
no que sea neta y si efectivamente la
luis garcía fuera este increíble lo que
estás haciendo por el fútbol femenil
como te apoyo como lo hacemos que
necesitas en eso me escribe margarita
zavala me buscan de club américa
club santos recién hablando hombre 1
marioni y se empieza a ser una comunidad
y gente que empieza a detectar esto
gracias a que empecé a alzar la voz y no
sólo me dicen está padre reunimos te
apoyamos y cómo lo hacemos estuve yo
mucho tiempo hablándole a la federación
y a la liga sin resultado por supuesto
de repente pasa que en las instituciones
encargadas en este país de hacer las
cosas no las quieren hacer tiene que
estar dando la lata así que hace un año
decidí sacar una campaña que
específicamente fuera dirigida a la liga
ya la federación para que no se
escucharan sí o sí
para su mala suerte y la muy buena de
nosotros esa campaña tuvo 10 millones de
impactos en un solo día
a
[Aplausos]
y coincidentemente es interiormente
casualmente después de ese impacto sale
el presidente de la liga anunciar que
vamos por fin a tener una liga
profesional femenil de fútbol en mexico
después de estos esfuerzos me marcan de
club américa me dijeron que era hemos
seguido todo el trabajo que has hecho
tenemos un proyecto integral porque
queremos que nuestro equipo de mujeres
sea igual que el de hombres sabemos que
hay muchos clubes que todos no lo
entienden incluso la misma liga pero
nosotros vamos con todo te queremos con
nosotros sí por supuesto todos ahora si
me preguntan digo que le va al américa
si no me corren pero
estoy muy contento trabajando allí ya
pasaron a 100 visita en un gran proyecto
la liga pues ya es una realidad con 16
clubes jugando lauritto
las semifinales son este fin no por
hacer promoción pero tú si les interesa
el tema lo quieren ver ahorita la gente
me pregunta mucho cómo llegó era pues tú
querías jugar fútbol ya está el sueño ya
lo lograste porque no estás jugando no y
me pasó una cosa muy curiosa
entonces de andar de footing género me
di cuenta que a través de lo que yo
comencé como mi sueño empecé a hacer que
los sueños de muchas otras niñas se
llevarán a cabo
y que cuando tienes un sueño personal y
lo cumples te haces muy grande
pero cuando aparte tus sueños
compartidos y cumplen los sueños de más
personas te hace estar ascendente yo no
estoy buscando hacerme grande yo estoy
buscando hacerme trascendente
cuando cuando santa me trajo las cosas
en ese momento que eran todas rosas yo
por supuesto odiaba el rosa pero lo
odiaba porque era el color que se me
había impuesto en el color que me tocaba
por ser niña y en las últimas niñas pues
obviamente con el color que me gustaba
mi preferido y así el azul haciendo
statements desde entonces
pues en este camino de lo que me he dado
cuenta y seguro comparten conmigo es
experiencia es que estamos en esta
búsqueda eterna como seres humanos de
cumplir nuestros sueños a eso venimos
aquí estamos para eso pero que la única
manera de poderlos cumplir
es escuchando a nuestro corazón porque
en repente se confunde cuando alguien le
susurra por aquí y le susurra por acá y
tú sabes lo que quieres pero esta se
escucha y escucha y te confundes pues
tiene que ser eso una plática uno-a-uno
honesta de nosotros con nuestro corazón
es el corazón
que puede ser rosa
o puede ser azul
incluso puede ser los dos colores
siempre y cuando seamos nosotros los que
escogemos su color muchas gracias
[Aplausos]